hello and welcome to this video playing
ESO call again i'm online mission to get
all the rating points back against him
it's got minus 4 score but I 11 games
the last one for example yeah it's
playing this old Indian here yeah i'll
just play normal development moose to
see what he comes up with takes okay
they're probably Queen takes here right
I can maybe take take the 95 for some
tricks I don't know
okay then just drop d 1 yeah should be
quite nice for watch big Center we get
pieces by black probably put my Bishop
to e2 okay like much to trade here but
what's difficult to avoid him
at least not Red Queen's him he's
usually lashing out with some active
stuff anyway so I don't need to worry
that much with my own progress he will
do something on its own accord pretty
sure about it it's not fall to any
tactics in my tix afore but it should
work
I don't have a clear idea here it looks
nice but it's not easy to improve on
this it's got some kind of decent yeah
holding position we also cannot do much
but ok so here it is I cannot take on
the six for what reason I don't know why
why am I not able to check them okay
don't see it show me 97 Queen Adelaide
asim queena 496 aa-23 Quint 83 oh my
goodness that wasn't that was a chance I
think for him okay um he played this
however you can also go e 5 hyundai t7 i
can take f sex okay i whupped his heaven
i mean i can take f6 for the back rank I
didn't I didn't see that move okay wow
I'm not really very focused him
so prothom can I just kind of still play
this what a game
now fatigue
27 is also interesting takes and then
takes f6 that could be interesting I
don't see why it wouldn't work but I'm
overlooking the easiest things here so i
might just totally blend everything here
the of course did too i can check here
wow I'm just nonsense and I'm very happy
that I'm not losing immediately here I
really deserve to lose this game for
what I overlooked here amazing I came um
this is actually quite interesting let's
see here now let's play it let's play
it's very difficult for him to get out
of this him okay check and then maybe g4
is actually interesting yeah let's
prepare this check check yeah and it's
going checkmated this is one of the
luckiest wins ever i played this black
reason completely absolutely out of my
mind i overlooked everything and I'm
someone just won the game amazing
overlooked everything absolutely
everything the knight on c3 yeah
absolutely crazy yeah okay well here it
looks nice for Wyatt he he defended this
well I thought I really thought that
this should be really bad for black but
the trade said it'd help and somewhere
around here yeah maybe i should actually
trade queens I don't know the way it
went it was okay for him again this year
that was ok again his pieces are kind of
okay these six is weakish but hmm I
cannot improve on that and then I came
up with this and this is just losing you
to this i think it's i saw this of
course but as i said he i can take and
then d 2 i'm just losing him so Queen d2
is a big blunder okay he didn't he
didn't take advantage of that and now I
absolutely overlooked at the night hangs
i play d 5 and that is this is not
losing it's just pure luck I didn't see
any of it rookie three back and now at
this Queenie seven yeah this is actually
good this is actually a good idea but I
here I thought rookie seven I didn't see
that energy to check but I have the
so as one of the luckiest games I won't
ever ya know Bishop f5 is winning so he
has to play Queen to be six yeah I'm
clearly better but 1.4 engine wise but
it's still a game and after night h5
membership h5 it's it's just probably
winning Oh 96 still is a fight g4 is
again a double ? bishop of 7s winning
now I need to keep this under control
and now this is win and so here he can
play this and things are totally know
the engine is kind of unsure here
anyways and evaluation is going up and
down I mean it's in the inner blitz game
it's a crapshoot anyway computer wants
to do this check check in g1 ok Queen h3
is not possible then she take so he's
not winning but he cannot check here and
probably draw like this Queen f3 pretty
funky stuff here g5 he can take the
bishop this check check check this is
what the engine is giving 000 hey there
was one of the luckiest windsor by I
didn't see anything here and still
somehow won the game ok thanks for
watching